Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Monday morning part.
Now it is.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Ah,
just checking in on you.
How come I can't fucking hear myself?
What do I get to plug this in right here.
Can I hear myself?
There we go.
Now it can hear myself.
You know,
can't hear myself.
Psycho.
I was talking with about,
with Dean del Ray last night outside of the comedy store.
He was talking to me about how,
you know,
you don't like when singers get old.
They can't,
you know,
they can't sing the way they used to.
Right.
Jason's,
this is going to be a long way.
You know,
like I was watching Christopher Cross last night,
you know,
my wife,
I came home and Neil was crank and you know,
say
no.
The boat,
whatever the fuck he says his that ran rant.
I do win.
All right man.
I do.
We'll get it right.
Listen to that shit goes,
look off such a lower to go listen to that shit.
So she was sitting there talking,
a fuck it,
I'll just keep going on this thing and I'll get back to dean in a minute.
She kept talking about,
she goes,
what kind of like fucking music is this?
She's like,
is this like soda of uh,
you know,
she was saying it was sorta disco.
He,
I'm like,
there really isn't,
it's sort of post disco.
What'd you call that?
Adult contemporary,
you know,
Kusa raw nuts
cause I like to wear and then it goes on such a low where to go
and they always have like the fucking,
like really like,
uh,
like to session musicians say like so good.
It's,
it just doesn't sound like it's even alive.
I,
you know,
it's weird.
I liked the music,
but just some of the shit,
like the drummer was amazing on those fucking,
it's just too slick,
you know?
I Dunno what the fuck it is.
But anyways,
I was talking to Dean and um,
we were talking about,
I hate when people like bitch,
when a singer gets old and then he can't sing the way used to.
And it's just like,
well,
yeah,
because back in the day they used to sing.
Yeah.
Like Robert Plant gets a ton of shit.
It's like,
dude,
you go sing the fucking immigrant song every night for fucking a two year tour.
You're just,
you're done.
Right?
If you watch,
somebody might not saying he can't sing now,
but I mean,
what do you want from the guy?
He's out there drinking booze,
he smoking cigarettes and he's fucking singing every goddamn night as opposed to
these modern day people who learn from the other guys the same way.
No drummer drives a Rolls Royce into a swimming pool anymore.
Right.
Did I almost say swimming pool?
Swimming Pool.
Right.
Nobody drowns in their own vomit anymore.
It happens every once in a while.
It fucking happens.
But you know,
you'll learn.
It's like when I came in,
um,
when I came into this business,
I saw a bunch of comics from the 80s that didn't pay and,
and fucking
senate all up their nose and they had their wages garnished and it was like they
were on punishment for like 10 years.
So my,
my wave of comics,
you know,
stayed away from the blow and the booze and that type of shit.
And then what was funny,
I got about 15 years end of this shit and I noticed that people started partying
again.
You know,
just cause I,
they probably looked at us like we were sitting there like we were part of the
Osman family,
you know.
So then another thing that they say is all wowed.
You see so and so man,
he got old.
Oh Wow.
She got old.
And that always bugs me.
So say,
well,
what the,
what the fuck happened to you?
You're not losing your looks.
Oh,
look at that.
You say that enough.
And now look at all these fucking celebrity.
So walking around,
they get in their fucking lips inflated.
They get net that Goddamn Botox,
you know,
inject it in their face so they can be like laminated to have that nice shiny
face
because nothing says youth,
like a shiny unmoving face.
Right.
I Dunno.
I Dunno how the hell I got into that.
Um,
I am going to go see a,
a,
I'm going to go to a rock concert tomorrow night.
I'm going to UNMUTE,
I don't even know what the kids call them nowadays.
Um,
I'm going to go see mute mass tomorrow night.
Very excited about that.
Um,
it makes me feel like I'm somewhat not an old guy to be going to this thing.
And a,
I'm so old,
I can't even like classify what their music is because,
uh,
I had,
I was hanging with a dean last night,
a couple of other people,
a couple of other oldies like myself.
We were all just coming to the realization that rock music is dead.
It's just,
it's dead and there's nothing we could do and it's,
it,
you know,
it's not coming back.
And if somebody tries to bring it back,
there'll be considered retro.
Right.
Am I out of my fucking mind?
But it sits over.
So last time you saw somebody playing a guitar,
okay.
I don't mean some Flamenco fucking shit or doing your acoustic version of a,
of a rap song.
I don't fucking mean that.
I mean like just somebody,
uh,
I dunno.
I know there's a lot of people scratching their heads going,
well,
what about all that death metal and all that shit?
I of course I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not talking about that.
I'm not talking about any,
anything.
I'm just talking about,
basically,
I'm just an old man wondering where the hair metal went 30 years after it died.
36 years,
maybe after it fucking died.
I'm just an old man rambling on a podcast.
Don't judge me.
Huh?
What about you?
What do you do right now?
You sit in a traffic,
right?
You're a little fucking car.
Drive over a puddle and the fucking water comes up through the floor boards.
You're judging me.
You think I haven't been there.
I'm fucking with you.
Um,
so last night to show is a Dean del Ray.
Just a sick fucking show.
I'm Dave Attell popped in who once again,
every time I see that guy performed,
stand up,
it's just,
I talked to Bart Nick and I was like,
is he ever not going to be the best?
Um,
and there's no way for me to say what he says or I'll say burn his jokes,
but he was just like,
he's one of those guys that he has me dying,
laughing and half to half is set.
I mean the dying laughing or I'm just standing there just,
just watching.
I'm just shaking my head like,
how the fuck do you come up with that stuff?
Um,
so one of,
I guess what I'm saying here is,
um,
I like Christopher Cross and if you have a chance,
go see David.
Tell,
I think that that was the purpose of the first six minutes,
right?
Is that what it is?
I'm not Jesus Christ.
Oh Geez.
I didn't tell you this man.
Like
I was traveling a lot and I was,
I was eating really poorly by last trip there,
uh,
when I was in a Foxwoods,
right.
Got To town early,
visited,
visited a friend of mine,
the one fortunate it was in the hospital but is now out.
And,
um,
you know,
so I was eating like shit that day and then I fucking,
uh,
went up to fox woods and I ordered room service and I lied to myself that I was
going to work out it on Sunday when I could have worked out.
I went to the Yukon game with Versie Versie hooked me up with the ticket,
the gentleman that he is,
and I went there and I like shit.
So,
uh,
you know,
you combine eating like shit and then getting on a plane for six hours and not
drinking enough water and then all of a sudden,
you know,
the train's not coming out of the station.
So,
you know,
one day the train doesn't come and it's like,
God,
maybe it'll come the next day.
It doesn't come the next day.
And then the third day,
uh,
you know,
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Trey never comes again.
Then the,
uh,
the station dice.
So,
uh,
I start thinking,
I gotta go to fucking,
you know,
I got to go to a pharmacy.
You get a stool soft,
no,
right.
All that shit.
But then I just got all paranoid and I was just like,
you know something,
the thing about the corporations is that they don't want to just get you,
they want to get you hooked and they want to have you keep coming back.
So I got,
I really started thinking about it going like,
well wait a minute.
If I go down and I take this stuff,
they'll probably be something in there,
in the little pill that tells my digestive track to just stand down.
Yeah,
we don't need you anymore.
Don't worry.
We got it all right.
Daddy's home.
He's going to take care of everything.
And then I'm going to become hooked on these fucking pills and I'm going to be
one of those guys.
You see,
having to eat blueberries every morning for fucking breakfast,
trying to turn his system around,
not realizing that he's fucking himself.
Fuck.
Cause he went fucking himself over it because he,
uh,
he's eating them fucking pills every day where he's going and getting them
fucking pills.
Right?
So,
oh,
freckle juice,
his brain.
And it's like,
there's no way that Julius Caesar never had a problem.
Taking a shit and I know that there was no cvs pharmacy for him to go to,
so I just looked up natural,
a natural cures in a woo.
I found one that worked for all freckles.
I know this is gross,
but it's a really important thing.
I went out,
okay,
it's a teaspoon of olive oil and then you squeeze some lemon in it.
You do it with the on an empty stomach and you're fucking,
you know you do a shot of it in the morning.
And the only thing I can compare it to as far as how well it worked,
you guys ever watch gas monkey garage and they get some old fucking car and they
haven't turned over the engine in a while.
All right,
so what do they do?
They take off the fucking the air filter housing,
all that shit and they got that shit.
They sprayed to the carburetor,
the opened the butterfly and they have it wide open and they go,
I give it a shot and the guy turns it over you.
The fucking thanks.
Starts showing up.
That's basically what I did.
You know,
teaspoon of olive oil and some lemon.
Can you do a shot of that on an empty stomach?
I mean,
you fucking own good.
You're all good.
You're on fucking grease rails for the rest of the day.
I stand by it.
I'm Bill Barr and I fucking,
uh,
I stand by this and I approve of this message.
Oh my God.
Just what nobody wanted.
Or at least I didn't want.
It's down to Hillary and Donald fucking Trump.
Unfucking believable.
How to,
how did we get here?
You know what?
Cause we
unbelievable.
No who do fucking,
both of those are going to be my two choices.
I'm not doing it.
You know what I mean?
Even though I didn't agree with everything that Bernie Sanders wanted to do,
uh,
I have to vote for a guy that went outside the usual fucking places to get his
money for his campaign.
Just to fucking encourage somebody else to do that.
And I really can't stand when people say that that's a waste of a vote.
I don't think it is because I think each time,
each election,
a guy like that gets a little bit farther and I actually think it's great that,
uh,
that the Democrats and Republicans,
the best that they could come up with at this point is Hillary Clinton and
fucking Donald Trump.
I mean,
Jesus,
all the juice.
This is fucking
okay.
I don't really think there's a lesser of two evil here.
I just,
it's,
you have it sitting on the last row of a plane,
you know,
and they're serving the breakfast and they're just like,
all right,
your choices today.
All right,
ham and cheese omelet or a bucket is shit with Granola,
right?
Yeah.
Like,
ah,
fuck it.
Then they go and you're like,
oh,
fuck it.
I'm going with the fucking ham and cheese omelet.
There's no choice here.
It's not even a choice.
Right.
We do have a limited selection of the practices,
so we apologize if when we get to you,
what you want is not available to Lee.
You're like,
I'm fucked.
And you just sit sitting there is every row.
Why wouldn't you just hear the you?
How do you see how you say ham and cheese?
Ham and cheese omelet.
Okay.
And if you said ham and cheese omelet every once in awhile there's some martyr
that goes it.
Yeah.
Take the bucket of Shit.
Right.
Um,
and then by the time it gets to you,
you know they're all gone.
Even heard of Sam.
Sorry sir.
I'm sorry man.
We don't have any more ham and cheese omelet.
I understand.
I understand you're upset,
but I don't choose how many ham and cheese omelets or on this flight.
Well,
I'm sorry you feel that way.
Well please go to American airlines.com/ org.net and I air your grievances there
and our robot,
we'll get back to you.
Right?
So then they come up to you and of course just,
you just have to go.
So you're,
all we have left is the bucket of Shit,
which you like that with the Granola,
the granola kind of takes the edge off of the shit.
Is that,
would that be okay?
And you still have to sit there and be like,
you just drag her through it even though it's not her fault,
you know,
you don't have what happened to him and she's on with.
Yeah.
You don't have any of that just started curiosities.
You ever started the back row and work your way to the front just to kind of
even it out.
You know,
you never do that.
How come you always start up front and work your way back to that poor excuse
for a of a kitchen?
Why do you do that?
You know what I mean?
So I thought that this was all coach.
Evidently there isn't,
evidently there's the ham and cheese party coach and a bucket of shit,
sir.
Why are you being hostile?
Nine 11 safe.
The terrorists,
the terrorists fight the terrorists.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
how the fuck did I get into that?
What was I talking about?
Oh No,
I was talking about,
Oh yeah,
the,
the fucking,
all the election.
Jason's,
I got so lost in doing that.
I don't remember what I was talking about.
Yeah.
That's basically what we're left with were basically sitting on in the last row,
middle seat right next to the bathroom on a DC nine.
You know,
we can't even look out the window and the engine is just blocking it.
And if you like me,
you heard of this story the one time the engine failed on the tarmac,
thank God,
but a piece of it flew through the fuselage and into this woman's head and
killed her.
That's what I always think about.
But you know what?
I also,
I also do,
it's because,
uh,
you know,
I didn't really look it up.
Somebody just said it to me,
but last night I did look something up because someone was trying to tell me
that some comedian,
actually an American comedian went to Dubai and had a little bit of coke in
there,
fucking suitcase that they forgot about,
got caught with it and got automatic 10 years.
Um,
and I'm just like,
really?
I go walk to American comic.
And they were like,
yeah,
dude,
American comic guys fucked.
Nobody had a name,
no nothing.
And I looked it up and for the life of me,
I can't find it.
You know what I did find was that there was this fucking half Iranian,
a half Swedish male model who got busted with some sick amount of coke.
Somehow got a life sentence.
They didn't kill him,
but they,
um,
they did kind of reduce it down to 10 years.
So he's got 10 years.
So he made a rap song in jail,
like dyke.
Remember that guy shine who was with j Lo and puffy?
I'm going way back to the 1990s when people still watch music videos.
Maybe it was the year 2000.
Right.
And,
uh,
what's his face used to do a,
the TV show.
Oh God,
what was it called?
Carson Daly used to do that show,
the top 40 fucking videos,
whatever the fuck it was called.
Um,
during that time,
right in members shine did the fuck.
And he did the,
made a song over the Rikers island phone.
This guy did the same fucking thing.
And I got to admit like,
yeah,
I dunno.
I,
I didn't,
I didn't have sympathy for the guy.
Okay.
Which is weird.
It's odd for me.
I was just,
you know what it was cause he was acting like Pete rose.
It was still all about him.
He was like,
I didn't have any drugs in my system.
I was blah blah.
It's like,
yeah,
but you were going to distribute the shit you con to,
he didn't give a fuck what happened and those people,
you're trying to make some money.
You knew what the fine was.
You roll the dice and you're fucking lost.
Well,
kind of an asshole goes anywhere in Asia with drugs.
You're out of your fucking mind.
Yeah,
it's fucking over.
They have a zero tolerance.
The only thing they do is make the drugs and ship it over here for some fucking
reason.
That's what I don't get.
If you get caught with drugs over there yet,
completely fucked.
But God damn it,
they will make some in a minute.
Right.
Well I guess that's Afghanistan.
Afghanistan is kind of the wild west,
right?
You'd think the fact that we've been at war with them for almost a decade and a
half,
you'd think that I would fucking know a little something about them.
I don't know.
Okay.
What do I know about those guys?
Who is the number one band in Afghanistan?
You know what I mean?
I love to hear what the fuck they would sing about.
Man,
that must be amazing.
You know,
just rebelling against your parents.
Are Your parents want you to take over the fucking opium den or a,
what are they called?
The opiate farm.
Okay.
You know,
I have a dream.
I don't want to do that.
I want to fucking,
I don't know what I want to do.
I want what
I want to raise llamas.
What are your career?
Right.
You know what?
I'm gonna look that up right now.
Career options in Afghanistan.
You know,
they've got to have a diversity over there.
One of those Suny fucking,
yeah,
Suny del high.
Fucking school's over,
you know,
just one of those schools.
They just have to,
you know,
just give people like,
Hey,
you go,
anybody can get into this.
We get it.
You just want to say it.
You went to college.
All right.
Career options.
This is probably going to put me on a list.
Afghanistan.
I went a f and then I lost my,
okay.
My nerve and I went a p.
H and s.
Gan is Stan.
Okay.
Holy Shit.
I spelled it right.
Jobs and Afghanistan.
Danger zone jobs.
Okay.
Got My skin peeled off.
Well,
building.
Fucking Starbucks.
Getting your head start off.
Did you do,
did you do,
sorry.
Okay.
All right.
Afghanistan,
jobs.
Employment.
All right.
I have career options.
Afghanistan
for natives.
This is still going to be us.
Space up opportunities.
Trump,
dangerous for Indians and Afghanistan.
All right,
well this,
this got us out of America.
Let's read about this.
Somebody decided not to be a teller.
Telemarketer,
right?
Her customer service guy leaves India and goes into Afghanistan.
Uh,
all can't even read this person's name,
but out of respect,
I'm going to spell it.
Be A,
R band,
Chanda,
last name r.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
If that was ever on wheel of fortune or you bought a vile and you said a,
if you couldn't solve that,
but even then,
if he didn't have any consonance,
you'd be that idiot trying to solve it.
Outgoing.
Ah,
a bad,
oh,
sorry.
Can I get a B please pat?
I'd like to solve it.
Ben.
A Chander ran or Jay drought shitty is fucking prices ever on wheel of fortune.
Zoe's for $700 I'll take the brass bed frame.
They always add the brass bed frame and like a fucking grandfather clock.
It's like,
what am I fucking 90
yeah.
Do you got anything from this century?
Okay.
For $40 I'll take the milkmaid for 17 I'll take the butter churner
oh,
let's see.
I guess,
what do you,
what do I have left?
$7 for $7 I'll take the tea cups set.
I'll take a polio shot and all the rest of it on a gift certificate.
Thank you.
All right.
Kabul,
Afghanistan,
banner Channer,
jolly rancher,
Jana,
Jay and Indian from the town of who?
Of radical dude.
All right.
This is the townies from U s I.
L.
You still lamp patty and Tamil Nadu.
Is it weird that did it met?
Made me want to get some Indian food.
Is there anything better than garlic naan?
I don't know.
I've spent and lonely independence day on August 15th at a Sikh temple in Kabul
or he had to,
had taken refuge after his Afghan visa expired.
Well,
how the fuck do you let that happen?
Mr Rander?
Jude had hash who came to Afghanistan on the promise of a job as a security
guard in an American military base for $800 every month had been swindled out of
150,000 rupees or 2,300 bucks by his employment agent in India.
Oh,
I'll tell you,
it's filthy.
You know,
after paying the money and waiting here for three months to 28 year old,
found out that there was no job and was left with just enough money for his
phone and his cigarette.
Oh my God.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Do People in like Asia just laugh at American movies like our ideas of what
trouble is?
Can you imagine that?
Can you imagine?
Somebody just said,
hey,
you want a job in Afghanistan?
And you go,
yeah,
I'll fucking do that.
I feel like there's a lot of American military right now nodding their heads
like,
yeah,
we know what that's like.
Yeah,
you get there and it's not what they promised.
Absolutely.
Um,
you show up,
you think you're going to be a hero and then they tell you you got to buy your
own uniform.
Um,
after paying the money,
there was no fucking job.
He's got enough money for phone and cigarettes while do that is just,
that is next level evil.
The Indian embassy in Kabul said that as of mid August 70 distressed Indians.
That's the way they put it.
Right?
Like posttraumatic Stress Syndrome instead of the classic George Carlin Bit bit
shell shocked.
Right.
Who was similarity,
similarity,
abandoned and were sent back to India.
All these sent back,
I'll thank God last year they were 160.
Oh,
so I see what this evil guy goes.
He goes,
well look,
then we fuck them over and then they get freaked out.
But then they just go to the embassy and then they pay for it,
you know,
fuck you on paying my taxes.
These guys will be all right.
And then they justify it,
right.
Then they go out and they buy themselves,
you know,
some shiny shoes and a car.
The Afghan Sikhs had given many of the Indians refuge in their temple and Kabul
a described them as mostly poor folk who had taken loans and sold off land to
pay commission to fraudulent employment agents.
They came with the hope of earning double the money paid for low skill jobs in
India.
Do you know when I landed,
landed in Dubai,
when I connected there with no cocaine in my fucking
suitcase.
Do you know that?
Somebody told me that,
you know,
there's basically the slave labor camps that total debt built Dubai and uh,
a lot of them were people from India and they get promised,
yeah,
you come over here,
you know,
the,
the poorest of the poor come over here.
You're going to make like fucking nine zillion dollars.
You're going to have a play station.
And then when you go back,
you know,
whatever,
you can bring your family over here and all that.
And they show up and the first thing they do is they confiscate their fucking
passports.
And these people just be,
they can't leave and they just become slaves.
And a,
the number one cause of death is like suicide.
You know what I mean?
Controversy at the Oscars.
I want,
I want to play a plumber.
American troubles,
um,
fucking unbelievable.
Unfucking believable,
man.
Well,
I'm glad this person got back.
Jesus Christ.
That's the type of Shit,
you know.
Do you remember that show arrested abroad?
I remember back in the day on the,
uh,
the opie and Anthony Program,
the tragically now gone,
Opie and Anthony Program,
one of the great radio shows of all fucking time.
I remember we were talking about that and we were watching that arrested abroad,
which just made you never want to travel outside of the United States again,
or whose kid?
No.
You know,
they made it really fucking racial.
It was just like,
you're white.
Stay in the white zone.
You could go to England,
you can go to Canada,
do not go south of San Diego or you are on your road.
Right.
But at the end of the day,
as much as these people were like fucking,
you know,
in jail,
they always,
you know,
most of them did something extremely fucking stupid where,
they,
they went out and bought platform shoes and hollow them out and put a bunch of
fucking,
you know,
heroin in there and a couple baggies,
a coke up their ass.
And it's just like that.
You never saw midnight express.
Yeah.
If you can find that clip.
I remember a long time ago we kept riffing on that.
That Irish guy would just go,
you know,
when he got busted,
he just,
I just kept thinking,
what have I done?
We want it to get done.
You fucking,
you fucked yourself over.
Get Dope.
Hmm.
I Dunno.
How fucked up is your life that like,
that's your option.
Yeah.
You'd like,
that sounds good.
Like,
I mean,
thank God I,
I just out of sheer dumb fucking luck.
Yeah.
Landed in the skin I have in the country.
I mean like I really got like at Delta,
you know,
a fucking an ace and a 10 I really did.
I've totally lucked out.
You know what I mean?
If somebody ever came up to me,
it was just like,
Hey,
do you want to put some heroin in your ass and try to make it across the border?
It's just,
it's,
it's an emphatic,
definite.
And the final as final answer.
No,
no,
I'm good.
I'm fucking good.
Don't need to do that.
You know,
dude,
I would go back to having a fucking paper like I did in the third grade right
through freshman year.
To be honest with you.
I would actually do that job again,
you know,
get a nice workout in the morning.
If I didn't live in a fucking city,
I would be a paper boy in a fucking second.
Was fucking great.
You got up before everybody else.
It was really peaceful.
It's quiet.
Fucking birds were chirping.
Yeah,
you had to deal with the weather,
but that,
that's what made you a fucking man.
You know,
you put on your Poncho,
you put on your thick socks,
fucking nostrils,
freezing together.
Oh God.
It was brutal.
I never,
there was nothing fucking better than when back when there were actually four
seasons on the east coast when the springtime came.
Okay.
And then you got up in the morning and you didn't have to wear a jacket.
I cannot even describe to you how fucking unbelievable that was.
MMM.
And the same way,
the ominous feeling is when it first started getting cold and you're like,
oh fuck.
Here comes another one.
Yeah.
MMM.
I told you this story before and I had this bike,
this fucking,
it was basically one of those beach bikes with white wall tires.
I was always a sucker for fucking white walls.
And I did,
I sort of pointed at the bike making fun of it.
My Dad loved it.
And he grew up in the fifties,
right?
Oh yeah.
We got big tires right there,
those big fucking peewee Herman bikes.
So I bought the bike and everybody was laughing at me.
All my friends had these,
you know,
pre like fucking,
uh,
we're all those fucking BMX bikes.
It was pretty BMX.
It was all,
everything was all about Schwinn,
the Apollo three speed.
They all had these cool bikes.
And I had this giant Fucking Pre pee wee Herman peewee Herman fucking bike.
And I remember one time my older brother took it and everyone was laughing and
he wrote it down.
The driveway is fast as he could in attires was so big and thick.
They,
when he fucking locked him up,
it actually made the sound of a car and went like,
yeah.
And then everybody thought the bike was cool and then they would,
you know,
that's how I ended up fitting it.
People will come along,
I look at it,
it's stupid fucking bike and I'll need to do is lock them up once and then they
laughed and thought it was cool and it was all right.
They all,
they look past my orange hair and my freckles and that's the way they did 76,
um,
anyways,
yeah,
I would do that job in a fucking second.
Somewhere along the line,
it became an adult's job.
And it was a combination of when,
you know,
we finally addressed the fact that there was a sexual predators out there.
And then also the show has made you feel like there was one behind every fucking
tree.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
so that went out the fuck the economy went to shit and it became an adult's job.
But anyways,
let me read the,
uh,
let me read the fucking,
what the hell is,
let me do the live reads.
Hey.
Oh,
sailing away.
Come on.
Come over here and syncs them.
Christopher Cross.
Oh,
I'll do the Christopher Cross bar.
You,
you do the,
uh,
the,
your your boy that Michael McDonald.
You that part,
right?
All right,
good.
So raw.
I like to win.
Shopped in,
it's something and now it's time for the Mica Mcdonald's fucking park.
Rah Rah.
No,
it was good.
It was,
it got such a long way to go.
Oh
wait,
is that it?
No,
there it goes.
Uh,
cause I got such a long way to go.
Such a long way to go.
Okay.
Oh God,
sorry.
I mean,
once in a while it has to just be for us.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Christopher Cross.
Right.
You know he's a big fan.
Him,
Jimmy Fallon,
Santa Mon.
He got him on his,
uh,
when he took over for Conan than he has.
He hit him on the tonight show.
Yes.
Yeah.
I can't find a was most annoying thing as much as you hate that you do it all
the time now.
That was the most annoying.
Stop doing that.
That was magic Johnson son Eja Eja and when he was talking about him,
I'm not saying he's a bad person,
but like,
he's just like going up because people would just walk around and get excited
about sunglasses and shoes and shit.
It's just like,
that's the big fucking thing.
The material.
Oh,
read the material is
when people were like,
yeah,
I was on his lay.
Yeah.
I love,
no,
it's fun.
It's like gross.
Look,
I respect somebody that has style.
Yeah.
Like when we watch and come on,
come on over to the microphone.
When you,
you taped a Chappelle show's block party,
right?
Yes.
Great fucking film.
Yeah.
So we watched that and when a Lauren Hill came out,
right?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Exactly.
Great stuff.
But she has sit around talking about her shoes.
I mean,
and then she goes out and crushes it and syncs this fucking sock.
Okay.
But for someone to just sit there and just sit there and talking or it'd be
excited about blazers.
It fucking soft garters and shit.
It's just,
I dunno.
And then Kiwi like just like your days all we're going to go out and go shop for
five fucking hours.
I don't understand B.
What?
I said I love it.
Hey by the way,
you know something I'm going to fucking,
I'm going to handle the garage.
Oh cause you know no cause you keep poopooing the whole thing.
Now I understand what yeah,
you know something.
If it was a common era,
it was a common area,
you would be excited.
You think I'm not interest.
Then having a little gym here at the House,
I think that's a great idea.
Who wouldn't want to have their own little gym so they don't have to go out to
work out.
Okay.
Now did you guys hear what she just said?
How did she describe it?
Twice.
Little.
Oh,
you little gym.
Yeah,
you guys.
you will still,
Vince used to have that bit.
Whose joke is that was well,
Sylvan insane.
I see in your,
your little Mercedes.
Oh,
you little Rolex taking me down.
I'm not taking you down.
I'm just telling you.
You know,
you're calm.
Tone is like when a pilot just goes through turbulence and even he's scared,
but he doesn't want to scare you.
So he just speaks in that calm.
I really hate when you referenced yourself.
I really hate when you reference your own.
What am I supposed to do?
I don't know.
It's who I am.
I don't know,
but it's a reference.
Your own self is like so annoying.
And so,
cause I've got redo the garage.
I don't give a fuck.
Fucking hell.
All right,
let's get into the,
uh,
the advertising for this week.
First of all,
if you think you're going to be this,
I'm building a man's Jim.
This is going to be out there with like,
like fucking uh Ooh.
You had a baby girl fucking risk weights.
You're pink.
Fucking getting shaped her awaits.
Its not going to be that.
It's like itching to beat the band.
It's crazy.
You gave her her allergy pill.
No I actually forgot to.
Did you really?
Can you come over to the mic so people don't have to lean forward into their
dashboard?
Is it driving here?
People can hear it.
You're the only one who screams into the microphone.
Like completely defeating the purpose of why a microphone exist.
I'm the only one who was screaming into a microphone.
No,
but
anyway.
Oh yes.
So what I've,
I've found what I want here is a rogue fitness.
Gee It would be nice if rogue fitness would trade some equipments or some free
advertising.
RML three w fold back Welmont rack.
Say it again.
The rogue are m l three w fold back wall mount rack made in the USA.
This is what's great.
It can fold back into the wall.
So if you have a small garage like me that's built for a fucking,
you know,
1928 model t Ford.
If there was one,
some gearheads we actionable.
Do we just continue in 1927?
I don't care.
I don't make them.
Um,
what's great is it has a pull up bar on it.
It's got,
you can,
you can move the thing up and you could do squats.
Nobody does their legs.
From my generation,
it's all about the upper body weight doing today,
judge,
to buy back and triage.
You ever going to do your legs?
Do it.
I walk around all the time.
Why?
Why do certain guys have like these little chicken legs and these huge upper
bodies?
What is that about?
Is that like,
that's a deliberate style,
like they're doing that on purpose?
No.
What it is is when you walk up to the sink and you flexing in the mirror from
your waist down is below the vanity.
So you can't see out of proportion.
You are,
yeah.
Yeah.
Plus legs.
It's not sexy.
It's not fun.
It's hard.
It's work.
Everybody.
I mean you go to any fucking gym in the world.
If you want to go bench press,
if there's two people in there,
there's only going to be two benches and they're both going to be occupied.
That's all guys do.
Every guy,
there's a zillion exercises,
but every guy goes over the bench press.
What do you put a little bull?
They do 25 I'll be full.
Good Times.
Right?
But all that other shit,
there's very few people that actually when you go to the gym have like a
proportion by the ladies are all about the squats and everything because that's
your,
that's your problem areas.
It's the biggest part of your body as the legs.
Yeah.
And actually if you build up your thighs,
your build up the,
that's the biggest muscle.
It allegedly burns enough fat.
And I could get rid of my belly here.
See belly belly.
I was trying to be a gentleman.
Nothing.
Oh,
freckled con Belew caught
nothing.
I'm not dumb.
There's a lot of the CB a pooch.
There's a lot of things.
You've got a baby bump.
I got it.
Um,
just a lot of too much for good.
Yeah.
There's a lot of good reviews or this thing.
I've got four stars.
Or is it five?
Five stars?
Yeah.
Have you researched it?
Um,
I'm going to handle all of it.
Do you tapped out this morning?
All right,
fine.
Fine,
I'll let you handle it.
You let me handle it and I'll let you know how it is.
And when I walk around and I'm shredded and I'm proportioned,
you're going to be like,
you know what?
God dammit,
I was wrong.
Are you going to put it in?
And I'll say,
I forgive you.
I going to put up a mirror somewhere so you can watch yourself while you shred
it and see what,
see what she's doing.
You little jam.
You going to put a mirror up?
I'll be right back.
You scared me.
You scared of what I'm going to become.
All right.
Let me read the fucking advertising so I can get on with the day here.
Track are smart cars,
smart phones,
smart homes,
technology.
Technology has made everything smart by losing your stuff's still make SMAD
people feels really stupid.
Tracker making,
losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that locates,
misplace keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything.
It's anything in seconds.
Oh my God,
I fucking need one of these are are you listening to this?
Just pair tracker to use smart phone to attach it to anything and find its
precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone.
No problem.
Cliffy press the button on tracker and your phone rings even when it's on
silent.
Yeah.
All right.
That's creepy.
How you hacking into my phone here with over 1.5 million devices track as the
largest crowd
gps network in the world,
so when you're lost item shows up on a map,
even if it's miles away,
never lose anything again with tracker listeners to this show,
get a special discount of 40% off your first track a device.
Go to the track at.com.
Actually it's t,
r not age the way I've been saying it.
And enter the Promo Code Burr.
The hardest thing you'll ever have to find is their website.
Go to tracker.com right now.
Enter the Promo code birth for 40% off.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code [inaudible] never lose your shit again and buy
shit.
I mean,
not literally shit,
but you stuff.
You still get pissed,
right?
All right.
Oh,
zip.
Okay.
But grow as a business owner,
your company is only as good as the people you hire.
Well,
no shit posting jobs in one place.
While that isn't enough to find quality candidates,
short staffing leaves time to post to dozens of Kj.
What short staffing leaves little time to pose to dozens of job sites.
Jesus Christ.
What is one to dope positions?
Zip Recruiter is the solution.
Well,
why don't you do that?
What the copy as opposed to making me do all the fucking leg work.
Uh,
you could post 100 plus job sites with one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates from over 6 million resumes.
Plus Watch brand new candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface within 24 hours with zip.
But Kroger,
it's been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Um,
today you can try zip recruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/bar.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr one more time.
Ziprecruiter.
Hi.
Zip recruiter.com/borough um,
one time we get to use it for free.
Well that's perfect.
If you looking for someone to fucking a,
you know,
oh Jesus.
40 minutes.
I'm only supposed to do a half hour here.
I'm working overtime and I'm on salary.
Alright,
have a great weekend and I'll talk to you on Monday.
Here's some more music from Andrew Feminists and he's the one,
he's the reason why I know about mute math and I'm very excited.
I'm going to take the lovely Nia there.
I'll see you guys in the crowd.
Uh Huh.
Did I miss most of the podcasts?
Yeah,
unless you want to do a little bonus time here.
How about you cleo?
You want to do some bonus time?
Nate Keshet.
Hello Buddy.
Just going to delete everything and get down.
Go lay down.
Go on.
Yeah,
step right on it.
Yep.
Step right on it day ago.
Get over on your bed.
Get over there.
Go on.
My mom laid out.
Did you talk about the Oscars?
I talked about the Oscars the last time.
What did you talk about?
I was talking how
white people fucking crushed it again this year.
I mean,
I don't really have,
are you allowed to be proud as a white male heterosexual?
Sure.
Your face is other people.
Uh,
I don't,
I actually don't have anything else to contribute this stuff.
You don't have anything else to contribute?
I wrapped up the podcast.
I did.
Sorry.
I know I got all excited and I realized I got nothing.
No,
I thought I talked Chris Rock's monologue was fucking tremendous.
I thought he addressed it and I thought it was,
we was well balanced and he's like,
yeah,
we're just looking for an opportunity you take.
You can't get mad at that,
you know?
No.
It is funny watching adults wanting to win a trophy though,
if that is funny to me.
Cry.
Um,
Eddie to be nominated for an Oscar though,
wouldn't you?
What's that?
What have you like just crushed it in a movie and there was talk of like at the
studio and stuff of you being nominated and they wanted you to do a campaign and
all that kind of stuff that I would like to be the guy that everybody says
should it got nominated and then didn't.
So then everybody feels bad for you,
but you don't have to campaign or go to the shelf.
That's the sweet spot now.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
You don't wanna be the guy that gets fucking nominated.
Then you got to sit there with the camera on your face as the guy with the
fucking good.
Good.
What's that?
What's that fucking kettle?
Kettle Drum,
right?
It's like the Timpani.
Yes.
Just like they're not going to give it to me.
Look at me.
I'm a balding fractal.
Fuck.
Right.
And then they give it to the good guy with the square jar and then he goes up
there and then I sit there going,
oh gosh,
such a long way to go.
We're killing.
This
was funny.
Fucking 12 minutes ago,
the first 58 times we've done it.
Yeah.
That's what I would like to be.
All right.
You want to be the guy that people said got fucked over because then people feel
like you're still,
there's you like the underground band.
Is that what you're going for?
Yeah.
Underground.
Keep putting your eyebrows up.
Like,
I haven't figured out this fucking business.
I have all these dishes who get nominated.
The next thing you know they're fucking doing crest commercials and they're
sitting court side on the fucking game and then people get annoyed because they
start seeing them when they shouldn't be seeing him.
And then you're just fucking everywhere and it's just like,
there's a hole in the ozone layer.
Hey Guide from this fucking movie.
What do you think about it?
Who I fit the constituents and he just like,
why am I listening to this guy from the reboot Brady bunch talking about what we
should do in Afghanistan and then you jump the shark and you're done.
You want to be the guy that people are going like he got fucked man,
that movie so much fucking better,
but blah blah blah blah blah.
Yeah,
you want to,
you want to be just underneath it so people know who you are.
So they still show up to see a dick and shit jokes.
But you're not overly exposed.
I like your philosophy.
Not that I,
there's nothing else to it.
I agree with you.
What I,
I seriously do.
I'm not joking.
You've probably said that like three times in the 12 years that I've known.
You said what?
I agree with you.
I agree with two.
I have nothing to add.
Yeah,
but I don't like it.
Okay.
This is like when Vince Vaughn was on Jimmy Fallon and knew Jimmy was trying to
get in his head when they were going to play a what's in the box that's fucking
bit it.
Call.
What's in the box?
It's fine.
All right.
I to go lie the liars box.
Yeah,
dude,
that was a clinic.
That was a clinic that Vince Vaughn put on there.
All right.
I'm uh,
I'm out of time here,
right?
Enjoy the rest of the podcast.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
All right.
Here's this sexuality situation.
Everybody.
Um,
hey bill,
I need your advice on something.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
not,
this is not about a breakup dating are gold diggers,
but I think your advice could help me,
could help me out on an extremely awkward position.
I'm 19 and I'm home from college for this Ama.
I've been home for about a month and I live in North Carolina,
but go to college in Arizona.
Dude,
good move Arizona with all those fucking whores out there coming to class and
like bikini tops.
And you're out there with your Q to than cute southern drawl.
How much asks are you getting?
Well,
let's find out.
Shall We?
Okay.
While I was away at college,
I have opened up to new ideas such as politics,
politics,
religion,
and about my sexuality and my bike,
and I am bisexual.
At the beginning of summer,
I started hanging out with my old friends from high school,
one of which was gays.
We had messed around in high school,
but nothing serious.
What does that mean?
You flicked his balls a little bit.
Sorry.
The fucking joke is there.
I'm going to do it.
All right.
Come on.
Take it like a man.
Like everybody else.
Okay.
Everybody gets trashed on this.
Here we go.
So this summer he and I were hanging out at my house and nobody was home.
We started and we started to drinking.
Oh Gee,
she's playing some music.
Why am ca and he started to smoke some weed,
man.
Then after about two hours,
we decided to do the dirty Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Here we go.
Login away through here.
Halfway through US getting it on.
My mom walks into the room and catches us in the act.
Wow.
Now talk about the needle going off the fucking record.
She started yelling at me,
wanting me with the mail.
She had just gotten,
I'm surprised you didn't turn the hose on.
You kicked my friend out of the house,
then banned him from ever coming over again and started screaming about the
Bible and a bunch of religious shit.
By the way,
this all happened when I was in a,
in a panic trying to get some clothes.
Oh my God,
Dude.
What a way to come out.
Okay.
Oh,
I think it was Mitch was a giant neon.
I'm gay sign hanging over you.
Wow.
That's a fucking situation there,
Huh.
Ever since then my mom and dad had been forcing me to go to a few religious nut
jobs that are supposed to convert me from bisexual to heterosexual.
That's hilarious.
You know like you're going to convert a truck from two wheel drive to four wheel
drive,
like it's that fucking easy.
This is a huge pain in the ass because one,
there are churches on every corner in North Carolina and two,
I don't want to change,
so you shouldn't,
dude,
you can't.
You are who you fucking are and they're going to have to accept it.
Also,
my parents had been treating me differently now and it's really weird and
awkward every time we talk.
So I guess my question is how do I deal with this?
So this is might be outside the realm of my lack of extra expertise here.
Do I tell them that I don't want to go to some religious fat fuck who a Jesus
Freak and whose stomach is as long as his vowels.
I always got that southern draw.
You can't be suck and day yet.
Um,
or should I just pretend to be straight until the under summer,
then go back to living the life I want to live at college also.
How do I keep saying with people telling me that I am living my life wrong and
that God is judging me.
I hope that wasn't too sad,
dude.
It's a fucking epic story.
Thank you for sharing.
Sharon it here.
Um,
all right.
This is a deal,
dude.
You,
you need new friends.
You need to keep the friends that accept you for who you are.
And the ones who aren't,
you just got to phase them out.
Your parents were,
your parents will come around,
you know,
they got to come around cause you're,
you're their son.
Alright.
Stereotypically,
probably your mom before your dad or whatever.
But I don't know,
maybe they will,
maybe they won't,
but what the fuck are you gonna do?
Okay.
You know,
you are who you are.
You got to go be who you're going to be and uh,
okay.
As far as do you tough it out for the summer,
that,
that stuff that's up to you,
that's up to you if you're going to keep going back.
I mean,
if I was going to keep going back to some shit that I wanted,
didn't want to go to,
I would just,
okay.
I would have fun with it.
I would just act like a fucking moron and I would keep acting like I was almost
cured.
And then at the last be like,
but don't you think John Travolta's
cute?
Oh No,
no.
Sorry.
I'm just fuck with the guy who just have a good time.
If you can't get out of it,
if you don't want to,
you know,
fight,
if you don't want to be like Hitler and try and fight on three fronts and ended
up in a fucking bunker,
uh,
maybe just start with to get some new fucking friends.
Uh,
that's it,
dude.
That's brutal man.
That's brutal.
But uh,
you'll get through it.
You'll get through it and you'll find some fucking people,
you know?
I don't know.
It's weird.
In a weird way.
Everybody does that beyond that shit.
You know,
as a comedian,
I never fit in anywhere.
Everywhere I went,
like when I fucking had jobs and they would be sitting there and I had my little
Michael J.
Fox fucking suit and tie on,
like thinking that this is what I was going to do and everybody was going in for
some fucking meeting.
I'd never gave a fuck.
And I never,
I just felt,
always felt like an outsider until the day I walked into a comedy club.
And I basically found people who were the same kind of weird that I was.
So they didn't seem weird to me.
A bit of admittedly,
comedians roll out of our fucking mind.
So that's what you have to do in a gay way.
You just got to go find some heterosexuals who are accepting of you and go get
some gay friends and uh,
you know,
you're gonna have a great life and you're going to have abs until you're 60,
evidently.
Cause that's how it works with gay people.
Fuck off.
B O u r and that's it.
There you go.
Yeah.
All right,
sisters,
a through c.
Here we go.
Tired of giving advice to guys with psycho suicidal girlfriends or people with
STDs.
Well,
I got something a bit later,
a few here.
Uh,
kind of like the cores lite version of your typical advice.
Thank you.
And it's perfect for the middle of the summer.
We kicked my feedback on this one.
So I know this lady who I've been friends with uh,
for a while now and banged one time,
she's the oldest of three sisters.
So we all call her sister a.
About two years ago I made out with sister be in a club,
not my initiative,
um,
and ended up having sex with her the same night.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
I went out with her.
Do,
do they have like that thing on the back of their SUV where they have the stick
figures of the entire family and you just slowly keep exiting them out
and the family doesn't understand.
Is somebody trying to kill my daughters?
No,
I'm just trying to fuck all of them sir.
Well that's a relief.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
I went out with her for awhile.
Oh,
this is sister B.
And it was surprisingly not awkward when we were hanging out all together,
even though everyone knew the situation.
Jesus Christ,
what's southern state are you in sir?
Um,
I'll go fuck yourself people down south.
That was funny.
Um,
some months later,
sister be left me for one of her,
one of my friends and got over it quickly enough.
But when you got over it quickly enough,
and nowadays I'm still in contact with sister a and B since I'm not the kind of
guy that holds a grudge for that kind of stuff.
Well there you go.
It's very mature,
which means you really didn't give a fuck about either one of them.
So why are you going to be all upset?
You know,
like you own their pussy once you fuck it.
I hate when,
I hate when guys do that.
Anyways,
recently census to see,
started talking to me more frequently after talking for a bit.
She said she could pose for me since I'm a painter and she's a model and a 10
all the fucking way I might add,
oh you fucking creep.
You fucking creep.
So she was a 10 the whole time.
So basically you're in a holding pattern banging her oldest sisters waiting
until this girl was of age so you could fucking painter Jesus Christ.
I got to,
I,
you know,
I might have to stand up and applaud this one.
This guy's taking it to another level.
Dude,
this is a fucking epic situation here.
So you go see,
here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Don't you need my advice?
I need advice from you.
How do you fuck every girl in the same family?
Jesus Christ.
This is like,
you know how long that's been a,
it's been since there's been a triple crown winner in horse racing.
The last time someone won the Kentucky Derby,
the Preakness and the breeders' Cup.
Is that what it is or is that a soccer match?
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
No fucking horse.
Since the late seventies I would guarantee that it's been since the late
seventies sent somebody has booze bank three.
I think a lot can do two in one family,
but to get all fucking three,
two,
three,
two is a respectable three is it?
No,
it's beyond respectable.
Two.
Three.
Okay.
Everybody knows was three is in the sporting world too.
That,
that's a fucking dynasty.
Okay.
You just put yourself in there with fucking Bill Russell.
You put yourself in there with,
with,
with the fucking,
uh,
Magic Johnson Lakers.
You know,
I wouldn't say the Colby Lakers.
You know when you go out and you get Phil Jackson and fucking check that,
that's that new ship that the kids like.
I don't like that shit.
Um,
either way,
dude,
you're talking fucking dynasty.
Oh wait,
magic never won three in a row,
but he had the Celtics to fuck with named when?
Three out of four years.
Give me a fucking break.
Um,
so he,
he's Michael Jordan.
There we go.
So here's my question.
Does that proposition mean anything?
Is it a trap?
Should I try to bang her?
Should I try and bang her too and get a third strike or keep my dick in my pants
and avoid a potential shit storm?
And if yes,
do you have any tips,
special tips on this special situation?
All my friends are telling me to do so,
but I thought I'd ask him.
We'll refine mine like yourselves before I did a move.
Dude,
you're looking at me like,
dude,
you're beyond me right now.
Okay.
This is like Bull Durham.
I'm fucking Kevin Costner.
Um,
I'm,
I'm a lifer.
Okay.
You're,
you're,
you're going up to the show pit and brand new balls every fucking day.
I will.
I will you tell me.
Okay.
I never banked two girls in one fucking family.
You know,
I was psyched if I was able to tag a couple of friends and we were all hanging
out at a bar one night.
And you get that feeling like I fuck both of you and you both know it and you
both loved it.
I hope.
Please,
please tell me you liked it.
Digital like it was.
I okay.
Um,
dude,
I think you got to do it.
You got to do it.
You know,
you,
you've been above board the whole time.
Sister,
rain since to be,
they all fucking knew everything right now.
I understand this is a little delicate.
Okay.
He's trying to snip the last wire here.
This is the kid sister.
This is it going to blow up in your fucking face.
Uh,
it's worth it,
dude.
It's worth it.
It's worth losing a couple of limbs and your nose on this one.
You got to do it
the fuck.
You know,
Dude.
What the fuck
she says to you?
I,
yeah,
you're,
you're a painter.
All let me take my clothes off.
He get paid my fucking Twat.
That's not art too.
That's foreplay.
Give me a fucking break.
It'd be one thing if you're in a classroom of people,
it's just you and she's standing there naked.
Dude.
That's like one of the depth they ever done that porn senate,
that scenario in a porn at Jesus Christ,
you might have fun.
A new angle
through.
That's phenomenal.
That is fucking phenomenal,
dude.
You gotta do it.
You got to do it.
Did John Elway retire when he only got one?
He came back for another,
right?
You got to do it to w
two that's like when Bush fucking the first Bush.
He stopped and he didn't get to sit down.
You got to go all the way on this one,
man.
All right.
You gotta be like Marlon Brando in fucking apocalypse now.
He just,
you just,
you just the fact you left the program.
All right.
And
okay,
I don't care how mad these girls get,
dude,
you are at the precipice of becoming an absolute fucking legend.
Yeah,
legit.
Who?
Who can,
who can,
who's going to be able to top that dude.
There is celebrities who've had orgies,
they've had five on ones and all that type of Shit,
okay?
But I guarantee you they never fucked three fucking girls in the same family
when they weren't famous,
not famous.
You're doing this shit with the gift of Gab.
Whatever the fuck you're doing,
do you do this?
You got to write a book,
okay,
you got to write a book.
That's fun.
You know,
that's what you should do.
Collection of the most amazing pussy getting stories ever that you can somehow
confirm,
all right,
and it has to be none of that bullshit.
The second you get famous,
you get money.
That doesn't count,
all right?
That's garbage time.
Okay?
They put the fucking second team in there and you just fucking Titone layups.
That's bullshit.
I'm talking about just regular dude.
You do.
You talk yourself into it.
[inaudible] you're a fucking legend.
You got to do it.
All right.
This might halftime speech.
I'm going to quote Joe Barton.
Nick quoting John Madden today is going to be the greatest day of your life,
but only if you win.
Okay?
By the
way,
I think it's time.
I think we're about 17 minutes in and think it's about time.
I patted myself on the back.
How about that?
Download speed last week.
Huh?
How about that?
I didn't hear any complaining.
You know,
hundreds and hundreds of people bitch,
Moan and and fuck.
Woo.
Right?
So I finally fixed the God damn problem and what am I get?
I get like five tweets going,
hey,
I really appreciate it.
You know what happened in the rest of you con you went on to bitch about
something else.
You don't like the photo on my fucking page.
You know,
you have a stop and thinking about,
you know,
maybe finding out what you're really upset about Jesus Christ.
Could I use that advisor?
Um,
all right,
let's talk about something in the news,
shall we?
You know what?
I think they shouldn't have to fucking sing the news the way they do in the
Catholic church.
You know,
there was a guy who got attacked by two monkeys in South Africa.
He decided he was going to go down there and try to rehabilitate some
chimpanzees.
Dad had been abused and they turn around and drag them for two kilometers and
kicked the shit out of him.
What a dumb fuck.
Why would you fly across the world to get your fucking ass kicked?
Did you guys hear about this dude,
South Africa,
Texas student attacked by chimp improves.
Thank God he improves this poor fucking bastard.
He's a ranger,
right?
He loves animals.
This is the thing about animal lovers.
You got to realize that once you go past a certain level of domestic animal and
you start getting into the wild,
no matter how much you love them,
they're not going to love you back.
Wild animals.
I like that.
Dick,
you shouldn't have gone out with you know that person have cheated on you.
That person who just doesn't have your back.
Wild animals do not have your back.
You dog has your back.
You cat borderline cats kind of have that creepy vibe that if shit went bad,
they'd decide with the intruder.
You know what I mean?
Fish.
They just don't have any fucking say.
They're like a Stepford wife,
you know?
That's why dogs are the best they,
it's,
they truly fucking love you.
My dog fucking loves me,
will be on a walk and all of a sudden she just look up me.
It's almost like she's smiling.
You know how fucking warped,
why sound?
She's probably just panting and it looks like she's smiling and she's probably
going like,
why does he have this fucking rope around my neck?
It doesn't make any sense to me.
If I really wanted to,
I could rip his fucking face off,
but in my world,
I'm so in love with my dog and look,
she's smiling,
but that's not bad when you just have a dog.
I think people who fucking,
you know,
fuck with animals for a wild animals,
they start thinking like,
oh,
look at the Cheetah.
Oh,
she's playing AAA and all of a sudden grow off.
This fucking launches itself that you
all right.
I believe that we came from monkeys.
I believe that we came from the apes.
I believe something else.
So there's three in a row in this sound smooth.
Um,
but I by no means think that,
uh,
that those fucking things like us,
I don't give a shit if I teach it.
Sign Language and the chimps sit net going in sign language.
Hey,
I think you're a cool guy there.
Freckled face cunt.
You know that there's no fucking way I'm ever going on the other side of the God
damn cage.
This poor bastard was on the other.
He was on the other side of the cage.
He just got too close.
That's how fucking insane a wild animal is.
Chimpanzees,
they say have the strength of six,
six men.
This dude got attacked by two chimps that would be like getting attacked by a
flash mob.
Okay.
Like 12 fucking people.
They just grabbed this motherfucker by his ankles.
They reached underneath.
I mean,
I don't what kind of bullshit cage they had was like a compound,
you know,
so they put up that,
that,
that cheap wire shit,
when you don't want to rabbit to come in and eat your lettuce right in your
garden.
Like they put that shit up.
So this fucking guy sitting there,
you know as they go doing that shit and he's like,
what are you guys joining Jeremy?
We adjourn telling me,
right?
And he's trying to sign to them.
You guys want to play Frisbee,
right?
And they sitting there talking to each other going just two more inches,
two more inches.
Look at this dumb motherfucker who wants to play Frisbee right?
And they reach underneath,
grab him by his fucking ankle
strength.
The 12 men,
they fucking pull them right underneath that God damn thing.
Like when you go to Quiznos and they stick you sub right through that poor
excuse for a fucking a brick oven,
yanked the fucker right underneath.
Oh my God.
And then they dragged them full like another fucking two kilometers.
However fucking far that is.
I don't know.
In my world.
That's a,
what's that about?
A mile and a quarter.
Cause I know like 40 kilometers,
like 60 kilometers is like 40 miles an hour.
Who gives a fuck?
They drag this son of a bitch basically through the length of every football
stadium in the NFL and I can guarantee you it wasn't the nice turf that those
guys play on.
This was the natural habitat.
Like I can't imagine the vice grip strength,
those,
those fucking things,
man.
They'll rip your foot off the rip your balls off the rip your face off the rip
it off.
Like you open a fucking God damn thing,
a yogurt God damn ice cream when you just take the lid off,
they do that to your face.
What the fuck are you doing near these God damn things.
You know
Jesus fucking Christ.
I would have to tranquilize had guns and I would be wearing one of those
fucking,
you know the suture where when you think you're going to get bitten by a shark
that chainlink shit.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way fucking catcher's mass welded to my face.
I'm not going to it in here.
And not only that,
these aren't just regular fucking chimps that have been swinging around eating
bananas,
occasionally eating another monkey alive,
right?
This isn't that shit.
These are ones that were abused.
They were already fucked with.
Okay.
And having adopted a fucking abused dog and the God skitzo Shit that that thing
does,
I can't fucking imagine
a God goddamn schizophrenia fucking ate two of them straight.
The 12 God,
they are men and you're gonna walk near the cage trying to sign,
hey,
how about the weather frank or whatever fucking human named he gave him.
You're right,
Yardi your fuck and God bless you.
Your heart's in the right place.
Fortunately,
this kid doesn't seem like he had any damage like that,
but like this dude was so in shock,
like they will finally able to just like stitch him up and stabilize him.
And evidently he's not in critical condition and it doesn't seem like,
it seems like he still has his balls,
his feet and his face,
which is incredible.
But they say,
you know,
he has bite marks and a and fractures plural.
Oh my God,
just treating me like a fucking rag doll.
That is the most horrifying shit in the world.
To me,
nature is the most horrifying shit I would rather have.
Well,
let's see.
You know what,
the human equivalent,
someone has to come into my house with a fucking chainsaw.
I can deal with the God damn.
I could deal with the machete.
All right.
I could deal with that.
Chainsaws that,
that's hardcore.
I could fuck up machete.
I could deal with,
I think I could fucking do the,
the,
the sugar ray Leonard,
you know,
stick my face out and then pull it back when you took a swing and then fucking
try to take both of your legs down.
Yeah.
Ah,
only hardcore boxing fans got that one.
Um,
but the,
I mean if you were in a room with the chimp and that thing goes fucking ape
shit,
no pun intended.
That thing is on the floor.
It's up on the ceiling.
It's across the room.
It's like,
it's like a comment and you're sitting there dealing with human speed
too.
That's why we got the brains that we have.
This,
why was so much smarter.
We have to be because we're so fucking slow.
You know what I mean?
You ever see a white guy who gets dunked on and those highlight films,
you know that fucking guy that they bring off the bench when the teams either up
by 30 or down by 30 that guy,
that's what we are in nature.
Even the fucking athletic humans,
you,
you know when nowhere near.
Just think like a how fast a fucking snake is a fucking pit Viper Viper,
right?
Nothing fucking,
you don't eat your bit and that thing has left,
left the fucking building before you even did,
before that signal from your fucking leg going,
hey,
we just got bit by a Goddamn pit viper even reaches your brain.
That snake is already leaving
and then you go and then the real is,
and as the realization that you got bit hits you,
you are,
you're already collapsing.
Why the fuck would you go out there?
You know?
I don't know.
We,
we had to be that fucking smart.
I can't imagine that the God damn fear back in the fucking
day you're walking around with a bunch of Goddamn neanderthals or whatever it,
Nina talls,
I guess I supposed to say.
I sit in the her fall my entire life,
but it's meander tall,
I guess.
And what else was it?
There was two tribes.
One of them died off.
There was an the enter talls and then there was the fucking crow magnums.
And I forget what the fuck we are.
One of them,
one and the other ones.
The other one of them's was a little bit smarter and the other ones were a
little dumber and dumber ones died off.
All right.
And some people have a little bit of that Crow Magnum or Neanderthal in him,
you know,
because you know that people,
they fuck right.
It's going to be the dumbest education of podcasts you've,
you'll ever going to fucking here.
I just totally lost my train of thought.
What the fuck was I talking about?
Oh,
Niana toss.
Right.
So I can't imagine what,
just fucking walking around.
Did you ever see that shit when they did that whole thing?
I'm crow manikins Indiana tall is like,
one of them was like fucking slower,
like the fucking white dude in the NBA and one of them was a little bit quicker,
a little bit smarter.
So they fucking did this shit where like when they would show him like taking
down some prehistoric bison,
like the fucking little smarter ones,
you know,
they could fucking,
you know that that Shit,
they could slip a punch,
they could throw a goddamn spear.
They could do,
they could do it from a fucking distance.
Like this fucking jackass.
He wasn't,
he was too close to the God damn cage.
The fucking Chromatin is whatever.
The dumber ones they would like fucking day would just brute strength.
They would fucking run and try to tackle the thing and someone would,
you know,
separate their shoulder,
a break and elbow and there's nobody around to set that shit.
Every step in your fucking nonexistence shoes,
your big stupid prehistoric foot.
It's just shoving that pain shoot through your body.
I just can't imagine,
I can't imagine sitting there looking out of a cave in everything is that much
faster than me.
And I don't have a fucking door.
I don't have a gun.
You just must be just sitting here like,
ah,
and he can't really communicate to the other person because language hasn't been
developed yet.
So you just having that,
what the fuck?
Look on your face.
That was probably one of the first phrases invented like,
are you shitting me or the kill you?
Can you fucking believe this?
I Dunno,
but God blessed that dude,
you're an animal lover.
I totally know where you're coming from.
But for the love of fucking God,
those things are not your friends.
Okay?
Okay.
I Dunno.
Start [inaudible] and stay away from that fucking cage.
Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine that
I am getting dragged away by two fucking abused chimps.
Then you know God damn well he saw that fucking Oprah won't episode.
That woman came on with no face.
I know.
We was fucking thinking of that shit.
I hate those mother fuckers.
He noticed.
I like gorillas.
I hate chimpanzees and I hate those little monkeys,
the little motherfuckers that throw their shit at you.
I can't stand those fuckers.
And I hate chimpanzees.
I always hated those motherfuckers.
I didn't know why,
and now I know why.
That was my inner fucking whatever the fuck caveman telling me.
Get the fuck out here.
Go back to the cave.
Stupid.
I don't trust them.
I don't,
I don't trust those fucking things.
You ever go to the zoo and you just fucking,
you'd just,
your eyes meet with like a lion.
Just that fucking look on their face when they,
they,
they just,
it's,
I've said this before,
it's like what the same look like when a hooker looks at you like it's,
it's the real deal.
You know this,
this is some fucking bullshit flirting,
playing hard to get,
get a couple of drinks out of you.
It's,
yeah,
you got 20 bucks.
I will suck your Dick.
What?
You know,
lions got that same look on their face.
Like,
yeah,
if you know,
if you weren't in that fucking armored vehicle or on the other side of this,
yeah,
if I was hungry,
I would eat you.
And no matter how much you screen,
that wouldn't give a shit.
It'll actually excite me more to rip your fucking head off.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
That's why I watch all those animal thinks about it.
I'm fascinated and I love,
and I appreciate all those people that put themselves in harm's way because
there's no other way to really gauge how strong an animal is until you see it
slap around a human being.
Like,
I can't watch too fucking grizzly bears wrestle and slap each other.
They're,
they're in the same weight class.
You know what I mean?
If I see him bitch slap a human being and watch the guys head spin around a
couple of times,
like,
wow,
all right,
I get that.
I can now gauge that.
Let's like,
yeah,
like,
like kilometers versus miles.
All right.
I think we killed that subject.
MMM.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].